[Applaus]
[Musik]
berg karabach ist eine jener region von
denen viele bis vor wenigen monaten noch
nicht einmal wussten dass es überhaupt
gibt jetzt aber es in allen medien von
bet karabach die rede weil es der
schauplatz eines offenen und brutalen
krieges zwischen zwei ländern geworden
ist und zwar des ersten offenen krieg
zwischen zwei ländern seite lerne ja in
den vergangenen jahren durften wir
mediale zeugen vieler kriegerische
konflikte rund um den erdball werden
aber dies waren fast immer konflikte die
von asymmetrischer kriegsführung beträgt
waren grill ja und bürgerkriege und es
sah fast schon so aus dass offene kriege
der vergangenheit angehören aber seit
dem 27
september 2020 bis zum zeitpunkt der
erstellung dieses videos hat der krieg
zwischen aserbaidschan und armenien
schon mehr als 6000 tote gefordert
darunter etwa 130 zivilisten
es besteht auch die reale gefahr dass es
zu ethnischen säuberungen oder gar
völkermord kommen wird
[Musik]
der groß dieses konflikts scheint die
frage zu sein wer berg karabach
kontrolliert eine region von 4.400
quadratkilometer in der etwa 150.000
menschen leben offiziell gehört sich zu
aserbaidschan aber in wirklichkeit
besteht fast die gesamte bevölkerung aus
ethnischen armenien
wir werden die in diesem video lief auch
genau erklären wieso dieser krieg weit
über bergkarabach hinaus wo große
geopolitische bedeutung hat aus welchem
grund der türkische präsident erdogan in
als stellvertreterkrieg gegen russland
anheizt und umgekehrt moskau in diesem
fall großes interesse hat das wieder
friede einkehrt es ist nicht das erste
mal dass es in dieser region wegen berg
karabach konflikt kommt der erste krieg
und berg karabach brach ende der 1980 er
jahre aus und kostete mehr als 30.000
menschen das leben eine million menschen
sowohl armenische als auch
aserbaidschanische herkunft wurde
vertrieben
seitdem gehören kleinere scharmützel
zwischen den armeen beider länder zur
tagesordnung zuletzt kam es 2016 zu
einem weiteren zusammenstoß bei dem fast
zwei us soldaten beider seiten starken
und 15 zivile opfer zu beklagen waren
sie sprechen von anklickt der jahrzehnte
zurückreicht und bei denen die
großmächte ziemlich verwirrt sind wenn
es darum geht welche seite sie
unterstützen soll
im moment ist das einzige land das klar
partei ergriffen hat die türkei sie
stellt sich ganz fest hinter
aserbaidschan
wer sind also die schulden in diesem
konflikt viele medien berichten über
diesen krieg als würde es sich ganz klar
um eine invasion aserbaidschans auf
armenischen gebiet handeln
aber die wahre geschichte ist viel
komplexer
also lasst uns zunächst die hintergründe
dieses konflikts beleuchten um zu
verstehen worum es eigentlich geht
im april dieses jahres war nämlich alles
noch ganz rosig aus armenien und
aserbaidschan steht kurz vor der
unterzeichnung eines friedensabkommens
auf der münchner sicherheitskonferenz
diskutierten damals der
aserbaidschanische präsident alijew oder
armenische premierminister maschine über
diese streams abkommen ganz zivilisiert
an einem tisch viele beobachter
rechneten damals fest mit einem ende des
jahrzehntelangen streit aber
offensichtlich haben sie sich gehörig
geehrt
internationale politik ist unberechenbar
und niemand verfügt über eine
kristallkugel was also ist schief
gelaufen und wie wird alles ausgehen
den wird russland unterstützen wenn die
usa und die eu warum ist dieser krieg
gerade jetzt ausgebaut
heute werden wir alle diese fragen
natürlich beantworten wie immer er hatte
dazu zunächst einen blick auf ein wenig
geschichte eine geschichte ohne helden
ich weiß welche frage euch jetzt am
meisten wurmt wer sind wir dieser
geschichte die guten und wer die bösen
im prinzip fällt das als ziemlich
leichte mit armenien sympathisieren die
armenier sind eines der am meisten des
stunden völker der welt geschichte um
die reine vorstellung von unsäglichen
leids zu geben dass dieses volk
durchleben musste im osmanischen reich
wurden mehr als zwei millionen armenier
bestialisch ermordet dieser erste
europäische genozid dienten hitler als
vorbild für die vernichtung der juden
und ist das urteil aller armenier
nicht zuletzt weil der türkische staat
ihn bis heute leugnet hinzu kommt dass
armin eine demokratie ist und eine
interessante bemerkung das erste
christliche land der geschichte war und
was können wir überall balkan sagen nun
es ist eine gruppe diktatur der
klassische fall eines landes mit enormen
gasreserven dessen gewinne direkt in die
taschen der herrschenden eliten
geflossen sind dies erklärt warum der
aserbaidschanische diktate aliev ein
vermögen von guten von millionen dollar
angehäuft hat obwohl seinem präsidenten
gehalt offiziell gerade mal 200 30.000
dollar beträgt das positivste was man
über dieses land sagen kann ist dass es
eines der ersten länder der muslimischen
welt ist wenn du denkst damit sagt
eigentlich alles gesagt und erklärt die
aus china seien geschossen und weniger
die guten die opfer dann erst du dich
leider in dieser geschichte gibt es kein
schwarz und weiß die region berg
karabach oder jahrhundertelang summe von
armenische
als auch von schiitischen muslimen
bevölkert was durch zahlreiche
volkszählung aus dem neunzehnten
jahrhundert bestätigt wird
zu dieser zeit waren sowohl das heutige
armee hin als auch das hotel savoy
anteil des russischen reiches im jahr
1918 wurden diese beiden länder jeder
unabhängig und ratet mal was geschafft
sie zogen in den krieg ein krieg der
damit endete dass russland diesmal
kommunistisch diese beiden länder erneut
über viel so waren armenien und
aserbaidschan auch passiert ist genannt
wieder einmal gezwungen unter dem
schutzmantel der sowjetunion zusammen zu
leben
seit der zeit stalins also seit 1923
gehört berg karabach zur sozialistischen
republik aserbaidschan
warum nun wie schon der zar und viele
andere kolonialmächte liebt es da liegen
die teile und herrsche strategie im
kaukasus und dazu gehört eben ethnisch
eindeutige mehrheit gebiete zu hindern
gleichzeitig wurden beide völker sowohl
arminia als auch seriös opfer brutaler
um siedlungspolitik in zahlreiche ebenso
wie unter stalin der zar sie diese zum
beispiel massenhaft armenien nach berg
karabach um welches anfang des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts noch
mehrheitlich muslimische die sieger im
jahr 1988 schließlich nutzten die in
bergkarabach lienen arminia die neuen
politischen freiheiten wie michael
gorbatschow geschaffen hatte um im
regionalparlament abzustimmen eine
abstimmung in der sie forderten dass die
region nicht mehr zu aserbaidschan
gehört und stattdessen teil der republik
armenien wird die in diesem gebiet
arminia beklagte sich darüber dass die
regierung in baku die armenische sprache
in den schulen und im fernsehen verboten
hatte die serie ist ihrerseits gingen
auch auf die straße um zu protestieren
weil sie nicht bereit waren die region
aufzugeben und dagegen wiederum
protestierten die armenier in eriwan
so brach der berg karabach krieg aus
[Musik]
ein klick der erst 1994 endete dieser
krieg wollte mehr als 30.000 tote
darunter viele zivilisten
und er führte zu mehr als einer million
vertriebenen die 850.000 sabana de der
region gelebt hatten mussten in andere
teile aus arbeitschancen sehen und
250.000 auf meliadine aserbaidschan
lebten mussten nach armenien umziehen
mit anderen worten wir sprechen von
einer totalen ethnischen säuberung
welche auf beiden seiten tiefe wunden
hinterlassen hat und diese wollten wird
man so schnell wohl nicht teilen können
und wenn du wissen möchtest wer den
krieg damals gewonnen hat und das waren
die arminia zumindest auf der
militärischen und auf der praktischen
ebene der militärische druck armenien es
war so groß dass wir nicht nur berg
karabach einnahmen sondern auch alle
gebiete die diese region mit armenien
verbinden das sind etwa 20 prozent des
territoriums von aserbaidschan was ihm
jedoch versagt blieb war ein sieg auf
diplomatischer ebene denn die republik
bergkarabach die sich ab 2017 republik
nennt wird von keinem land der welt
anerkannt paradoxerweise nicht mal von
armenien selbst und das obwohl kein
staat ist in dem die polizeit armenische
ist ebenso wie die währung und die
ansprache ist so sehr armenisch das
sogar zwei der letzten armenischen
präsidenten den stepper nach herz der
hauptstadt der republik geboren wurden
all dies wird uns verstehen warum dieser
krieg nicht zu ende ging es gab nie ein
friedensabkommen es wurde lediglich ein
waffenstillstand vereinbart seit 1992
versuchte die osze die organisation für
sicherheit und zusammenarbeit in europa
beide seiten zusammenzubringen um ein
territoriales abkommen auszuhandeln
dabei kam ist traut jedoch den führenden
ländern frankreich russland und usa
zutiefst und war nie bereit unter ihrem
vorsitz friedensverhandlungen zu führen
warum nun das geht ganz einfach daran
dass sowohl in frankreich als auch in
russland und den usa eine riesige
armenische diaspora lebt und der hass
auf alle armenier oder arm eine ständige
menschen ist eines der wichtigsten
schlüssel instrumente der machtpolitik
der mechanischen herrscher familie allee
natürlich fällt ist nach der vertreibung
von mehr als 800.000 series durch
armenien nicht besonders schwer diesen
anti armenischen hass zu schüren und
über lange zeit am leben zu erhalten hat
der sich ihnen aussagen wie dieser
niederstreckt
unsere hauptfeinde sie die arminia der
welt und die heuchlerischen und
korrupten politiker unter ihrer
kontrolle haben als präsident von
aserbaidschan der instrumentalisierung
hass auf armenien ist für die familie
aliev zum perfekten politischen
instrument geworden um alle arten von
machtmissbrauch zu rechtfertigen und ich
will mal ein beispiel dafür geben wie
weit dieses gefährliche narrativ geht
selbst menschen die kim kardashian
gelten aserbaidschan als staatsfeinde
dann kardashian ist armenischer herkunft
und damit wird das regime in baku eine
weitere von vielen armenien die überall
auf der welt und die albanische
propaganda verbreiten bereits zu beginn
diese videos habe ich dir davon erzählt
welche leidvolle geschichte das
armenische volk hinter sich hat nun
diese geschichte voller verfolgung
vertreibung und völkermord hat dazu
geführt dass außerhalb armee ist heute
dreimal so viele arme leben wie in
armenien selbst rund um die welt
verstreut leben bis zu zehn millionen
innerhalb der eigenen staatsgrenzen nur
knapp drei millionen und die größten
auslands communitys befinden sich in
russland den usa und frankreich aber
haben sie wirklich so viel einfluss auf
die politik dieser staaten und die
friedensverhandlungen oder ist arbeit
schauen einfach nur total paranoid nun
so einfach ist das leider nicht denn
immer dann wenn die regierung in eriwan
zum einlenken bereit ist gretchen die
wichtigen verbände der auslands armenien
zwischen diese sind meist nur dazu
bereit den status quo beizubehalten das
heißt die republik als auch die
besetzten angrenzenden gebiete
ethnischen rein zu halten eine rückkehr
der vertriebenen series ausgeschlossen
so haben sich beispielsweise die
außenminister armeniens und
aserbaidschans im jahr 2007 in madrid
auf eine reihe von grundprinzipien
verständigt diese prinzipien bis sagen
dass armenien die gesetzten angrenzenden
gebiete aserbaidschan zurückgibt und
beide seiten allen vertriebenen ein
recht auf rückkehr gewähren außerdem
solle ein korridor zwischen armenien und
der karabach eingerichtet werden und in
regierungs selbst ein referendum
stattfinden in welcher über die
selbstbestimmung entschieden sagt okay
das klang doch alles recht günstig oder
also wieso wurde nichts daraus
nun zum einen war es unter den
regierungen strittig in welcher
reihenfolge diese prinzipien umzusetzen
sein
denn preston würde ja schon ein riesen
unterschied machen ob das referendum
durchgeführt würde bevor oder nachdem
alle arbeit charme macht berg karabach
zurückkehren sind außerdem müsste das
was der endung von internationalen
sicherheitskräften überwacht werden was
einen zumindest teilweisen rückzug der
armenischen truppen voraussetzen würde
und das ist etwas was die armenische
diaspora nicht akzeptiert als voran die
mächtige medien association of america
sie lehnte dieses vorgehen als
undemokratisch ab daher blieb alles beim
alten
keine seite war bereit einen millimeter
weiter zu gehen und keine großmacht
konnte sich durchringen eine der beiden
seiten klar zu unterstützen eine sache
änderte sich in all den jahren jedoch
ganz gewaltig die wirtschaft 1994 waren
armenien aserbaidschan 2 gleich arme
länder in einer art pattsituation
verfügt beide länder über ein ähnliches
maß an macht und beschlossen daher einen
waffenstillstand zuzustimmen
seitdem ist es wirtschaft mit der
gleichen geschwindigkeit gewachsen wie
alle übrigen länder der region mit
ausnahme japans dessen geschichte
verlief völlig anders denn im jahr 1999
entdeckt das hat etwas das seine
wirtschaft immer veränderte tief unter
dem kaspischen meer erwarten eine
billion kubikmeter darauf angesetzt zu
werden
wir sprechen über die gasfelder von shah
deniz im kaspischen meer eines der
größten gasfelder der welt überhaupt
plötzlich schoss das
bruttoinlandsprodukt also bei charles in
die höhe zieht einmal dazu folgende
grafikkarten
mit hilfe der gasförderung konnte also
weit schauen dass dpa - mittlerweile
umfasst das vierfache übertreffen
und ein gewaltiger teil dieses reichtums
floss das militär aber nicht nur das
doch mal was so alles passieren kann
wenn jemand quasi über nacht vom armen
schlucker zum rohstoff gegangen wird
genau
plötzlich wollen alle deine freunde sein
auch wenn sie sich vorher noch nicht mal
mit der kneifzange angefasst hätten und
zwar dem also weit fahren so einer das
macht geworden ist hat es nicht
aufgehört verteidigungsabkommen mit
einer ganzen reihe von ländern zu
unterzeichnen unter anderem mit russland
israel und der türkei
und so kam es wie es kommen musste den
regime in baku wurde so langsam bewusst
dass sich das gleichgewicht zu seinen
gunsten verschoben hatte und der
waffenstillstand nicht mehr besonders
vorteilhaft für sie war
[Musik]
gewalt in bergkarabach schlimmsten
zusammenstöße seit jahrzehnten dutzende
bbc diese nachricht stammt aus dem jahr
damals dauerte der krieg fünf tage und
forderte 200 todesopfer trotz der
tatsache dass also bei schaan überbot
der andere waffen verfügte gelangt es in
armenien die mittlerweile eigentlich
überlegenen truppen bacchus aufzuhalten
aber da ist überhaupt möglich 0
also bezahlen wollte ganz einfach seine
überlegenheit gegen armenien und dann
weiß stellen und musste am ende
herausfinden dass krieg nicht nur eine
frage von viel geld und euren waffen ist
es hätte zum beispiel mal saudi arabien
fragen sollen wie ist eine alte karte
gegen einen haufen rebellen im jemen ist
was arbeit schafft wohl auch nicht dass
das das gesamte umkämpfte gebiet seit
jahren von armenischen truppen
kontrolliert wird die sich dort
vortragen und auskennen und über die
sehr gut ausgebildet sind wieder einmal
schien also ein gewisses gleichgewicht
der kräfte im spiel gewesen zu sein
tja das war vor vier jahren bei der
diesjährigen offensive als er bei chance
sieht es jedoch ganz anders aus die
armenien müssen eine niederlage nach der
anderen einstecken
du fragst dich also was hat sich
gegenüber der lage von fünf jahren
geändert und aufstände um die antwort
auf diese frage zu finden müssen wir
unsere koffer packen und in ein ganz
anderes land reisen
das erwachen des osmanischen riesen der
fünfzehnte juli 2016 wird für immer als
das datum ist gescheitert putsches gegen
den türkischen präsidenten recep tayyip
erdogan in erinnerung bleiben erdogan
bezeichnete diesen putsch gegen ihn als
ein geschenk gottes denn er bot ihnen
den perfekten vorwand als seine gegner
innerhalb der armee zu liquidieren
die verfassung des landes nach seinem
brust so umzuschreiben und damit noch
mehr macht zu erlangen
die türkische armee war traditionell
nämlich durch und durch kemalistisch das
heißt sie verteilte dem werte der von
mustafa kemal atatürk 1923 gegründeten
republik türkei
der türke war ein anhänger des
republikanismus und des laizismus also
trennung zwischen religion und staat
dies war erdogan natürlich lange ein
dorn im auge denn eine seekuh leer und
westlich ausgerichtete türkei ist genau
das gegenteil seiner eigenen agenda des
neo obmann ismus dh der rückumwandlung
der modernen türkei in einem von
mittelalterlichen vorstellungen
geprägtes osmanisches reich irgendwas
zwischen einem konservativen gottesstaat
und seine persönlichen sultanat und wie
die sich ja vorstellen kannst ist es für
die durchführung einer solchen
expansionspolitik unerlässlich die armee
und der totaler kontrolle zu haben
erdogan soll nach b und justiz nach
gescheiterten putsch all dies erklärte
wende welche die türkische politik seit
2006 zugenommen hat für das anheizen des
aggressiv expansionistischen türkische
nationalismus hat erdogan jedoch noch
einen anderen grund im grunde hängt
seine politische existenz womöglich sein
überleben daran
wieso nun hast du dir mal in letzter
zeit angesehen wie es der türkei
eigentlich wirtschaftlich geht wir haben
schon vor einiger zeit ein video darüber
gedreht und darin vieles von den vorher
gesagt was ich gerade abspielt die
türkei befindet sich in einer sehr sehr
schweren wirtschaftskrise der tiefpunkt
noch lange nicht absehbar ist im jahr
2013 das türkische bip bei 951
milliarden dollar
sechs jahre später im jahr 2009 10 bei
nur noch 7 154 milliarden dollar ein
absturz von über 20% und was in einer
zeit des globalen aufschwungs in der dbp
so gut wie aller länder stiegen und
stiegen
denn der absturz ins bodenlose während
der korona krise ist hier noch gar nicht
berücksichtigt besonders prekär
türkische unternehmen haben sich
unglaublich großem umfang in
ausländischen währungen dollar und euro
verschuldet und rational was gerade mit
den kurs der türkischen lira passiert im
jahr 2010 hast du für einen euro gerade
mal zwei lehrer bekommen und heute droht
ein absturz und sage und schreibe 80
prozent im grunde heißt das dass die
türkei bei ausländischen investoren
jegliches vertrauen verspielt hat und
wahrscheinlich vor einer hyperinflation
steht erdogan hat die zentralbank die
eigentlich unabhängig sein sollte und
dass eine volle kontrolle gebracht und
versucht jetzt die wahren
inflationsraten der türkei mit aller
macht zu vertuschen
wie sonst ließe sich erklären dass die
offizielle inflationsrate im juli 2020
11,78 prozent betrug im august 11,77 und
im september 11,75 prozent
dies ist eine gleichmäßigkeit ihr sonst
noch nirgends auf der welt gab wenn
fingierte statistiken aber das
schlimmste mittel wären mit dem erdogan
von seinem kolossalen versagen
abzulenken versucht dann wäre die welt
eine bessere nein leider sind sie es
nicht denn dieses ist krieg er dolls
armee ist an allen möglichen fronten
präsent werfen wir einen blick auf diese
karte
ich stelle die jetzt mal die doktrin
namen smaghi warnt vor zu deutsch blaue
heimat von dieser doktrin wirst du in
den kommenden monaten wahrscheinlich
noch öfter hören und worum geht es darin
nun die türkei alle meere kontrollieren
die sie umgeben das mittelmeer die igs
und das schwarze meer
das erklärt warum der türken in krieg in
libyen so präsent sind und warum sie mit
griechenland auf konfrontationskurs
gehen aber nicht nur das die türkei ist
auch an der kontrolle des persischen
golfs und des kaspischen meers
interessiert und du wirst dich
wahrscheinlich fragen warum erdogan
gerade diese mehrere so stark
interessieren nun aus zwei gründen zum
einen um seine ultra nationalistischen
fans zu bedienen und zum anderen weil
die energie das auge davon abhängt ist
vor kurzem kann das von der türkei
benötigte öl und gas von zwei
lieferanten russland und iran
beide länder waren traditionell
antagonisten doch ab 2019 begann sich
die dinge zu ändern
die türkei und aserbaidschan markieren
die fertigstellung der pipeline die gas
nach europa bringen soll
erinnerst du dich daran wie ich von
erdogan der osmanische agenda strache
dabei handelt es sich eigentlich um eine
form des nationalismus was bedeutet das
nun es bedeutet dass der neue türkische
nationalismus weniger auf religion oder
auf einem politischen system basiert
sondern auch einer gemeinsamen wachse
und kultur die a-serie sind eintracht
ist folglich viele avatare bezeichnet
sich aufgrund einer ansprache zur
verwandtschaft zu den türken als
amerikanische türken sowohl alle jäger
als auch erdogan spielen mit bravour auf
dieser ethno nationalistischem klaviatur
und kommen genau deswegen so gut
miteinander aus sie brauchen sich
gegenseitig gut ihre nationalistische
klientel zu bedienen den früheren videos
von visual politik haben wir von der
türkischen rüstungsindustrie erzählt die
erdogan wiederbelebt hat jetzt hat die
türkei ihre eigenen raketenwerfer
laserwaffen und sogar ihre eigenen
drohnen ein sehr beliebtes modell ist
die bayraktar tb2 und einer ihrer
größten abnehmer ist kein geringerer als
aserbaidschan
[Musik]
türkei und aserbaidschan vertiefen die
zusammenarbeit der
verteidigungsindustrie mit einem neuen
bilateralen abkommen diese schlagzeile
stammt aus dem mai 2020 zu diesem
zeitpunkt war die passage spanische
armee sehr gut mit türkischen russischen
und israelischen waffen ausgerüstet und
damit statt in baku eines fest wir
können die armenier endlich besiegen
nicht nur diktator lief kam zu diesem
schluss sind auch das volk selbst
japanische demonstranten vor dem krieg
nach den zusammenstößen in armenien und
während zu dieser zeit einige länder wie
zum beispiel kanada beschlossen kein
weiteres öl ins feuer zu gießen und
waffenverkäufe nach arbeit verboten
ermutigte erdogan allium ja eine
vorstellung zu vermitteln
die türkische unterstützung der
japanischen armee ist so offensichtlich
dass er sogar auf der offiziellen
webseite des afghanischen
verteidigungsministeriums bilder wie
diese finden können
[Musik]
aber ich weiß was nicht jetzt wollt ist
die unterstützung der türkei in diesem
krieg denn so entscheidend sie ist doch
nicht das einzige land dass
aserbaidschan waffen liefert nun ich
kann dir versichern
gerade die türkische unterstützung ist
entscheidend und um dies zu verstehen
müssen wir in ein weiteres land reisen
und ist jahr 2012 aufgepasst denn was
jetzt kommt ist geradezu ein hollywood
reifer spionage thriller um mögliche
bündnisse jury im jahr 2012 syrische
rebellen erheben sich gegen diktator
assad viele fordern den usa zum
eingreifen auf der damalige präsident
barack obama hat eine tolle idee
er nimmt den weg des geringsten
widerstands und ruft die jungs in
langley an
sie sollen diesen rebellen doch mal
unter die arme greifen und so
schließlich sei das programm
kinder 6 bis heute ist dieses programm
geheim so dass es nur wenige
informationen darüber gibt was wir aber
wissen ist dass dies ihre waffen auf dem
schwarzmarkt gekauft hat auf dem balkan
welche art von waffen nachsicht brillen
danach der affe und so weiter mit diesen
waffen wurden dann die
unterschiedlichsten gruppierungen die
gegen assad kräften ausgerüstet außerdem
verpasste sich ja in diesen kämpfern
eine erstklassige ausbildung und jetzt
kannst du dir sicher schon vorstellen
obamas idee stellte sich im nachhinein
nicht nur als ziemlich beschissen heraus
nein das war nicht das erste mal dass
die usa mit ihrer rüstung und ausbildung
ihre eigenen feinde erschließen
obama beginnt damit derselben fatalen
fehler drin sein vorgänger jimmy carter
in afghanistan begangen hatte
dieser ließ 1979 ebenfalls ich sie die
mudschaheddin in afghanistan mit waffen
und ausbildung zu versorgen damit diese
gegen die sowjetunion kämpfen damit er
schuf er die gefährliche saat aus der al
qaida hervorging jede terrortruppe
welche das attentat auf die
zwillingstürme in manhattan an eleven
und viele andere anschläge zu
verantworten hatte welche stürme aus
obama
barth hervor gehen wir haben in letzter
zeit noch nicht überblicken was wir aber
wissen ist dass viele von der cia
ausgebildeten gruppierungen extrem
zweifelhafter natur waren und der
gesamtumfang von tindersticks ist immer
noch unbekannt und es ist immer noch
nicht klar wer alles diese waffen und
die ausbildung von daher überhaupt
erhalten hat klar ist jedoch dass donald
trump das team erste kammer programm
sofort eingestellt hat kommt dass er
sich das erste mal im openoffice hinter
seinem schreibtisch
dieser ließ aber das problem ist diese
zahl passt da kann auch trotz nicht mehr
in die tube zurück drücken so blieben
zehntausende syrischer guerilla kämpfer
mit erstklassiger militärische
ausbildung in freier wildbahn unterricht
und hier kommt die tür kein spiel
es entstand die syrische nationale armee
eine gruppe von söldnern im dienste der
türkei jeder dieser söldner bekommt aus
anderer ein sold von 1500 bis 2000
dollar pro monat und hat das recht die
türkische staatsbürgerschaft zu
beantragen
erinnerst du dich noch daran wie ich
erklärt habe dass er weit schaden dem
krieg von 2016 trotz besserer wachen
verloren hat weil die japanische armee
nicht gut genug ausgebildet war sowie
die armee ist nun genau dieses problem
hat die türkei ist lösen können
es wird geschätzt dass zwischen 700 und
1000 erstklassig ausgebildet und
karussellfahren historische bilder die
in ankara unter vertrag stehen in berka
bakri kämpfen natürlich bestreitet
erdogan das alles aber schlagzeilen wie
diese sprechen einfach zu sich der bach
mindestens drei historische kämpfer
getötet
wir haben also auf der einen seite
aserbaidschan das viermal so viel geld
hat wie armenien große gasreserven und
die bedingungslose unterstützung der
türkei und ihrer von der cd
ausgebildeten syrischen zellner und auf
der anderen seite wer unterstützt
armenien einer seiner möglichen
verbündeten wäre der iran nach dem motto
der feind meines feindes ist mein freund
aber im moment beschränkt sich der iran
einfach nur darauf seine eigenen grenzen
mit der aufstellung von rund 200 panzern
zu sichern er will nicht dass er kriegt
irgendwie auf seine seite über greift
dann hätten wir russland
es ist ein traditioneller verbündeter
armenien nach der schlicht hat russland
in armenien selbst eine militärbasis mit
mehr als 3000 soldaten
darüber hinaus ist familienmitglied der
organisation des vertrags über
kollektive sicherheit die so etwas wie
die russische nato ist wenn
aserbaidschan armee angreifen würde wäre
russland im prinzip verpflichte sich zu
seiner verteidigung zu stellen und dass
herr russland zu sagen was steht hat
präsident putin dänischen
premierminister bei gemeinsamen
beratungsgesprächen nochmals versichert
auch wenn er ebenfalls anmerkte dass
russland zu beiden kontrahenten gute
beziehungen unterhalten und nicht
eingreifen wolle solange armenien nicht
auf seinem eigenen staatsgebiet
angegriffen würde denn wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass becker rabatt offiziell
zu bald schon gehört technisch gesehen
ist was arbeit fahren also wenn kein
fremdes land eingeräumt aus
völkerrechtlicher sicht versucht es
lediglich ein gebiet zurück zu erobern
das ihm zusteht die wende und sie ist
aber dass mit dem völkerrecht mal
genauer ansehen merken wir sehr schnell
dass seine anwendung durch die
internationale staatengemeinschaft alles
andere als einheitlich ist im falle der
abspaltung des kosovo von serbien zum
beispiel ist der internationale
gerichtshof zur erkenntnis gekommen dass
eine unabhängigkeitserklärung dann im
einklang mit dem völkerrecht steht wenn
sie gegen keine anwendbare regel ist
völkerrecht verstößt das prinzip der
territorialen
qualität worauf sich staaten in der
regel rufen wenn sie die ausstattungen
von regionen verhindern wollen kann das
selbstbestimmungsrecht dieser region
also gar nicht aushebeln
es ist also sehr deutlich zu erkennen
dass die internationale
staatengemeinschaft unter einzelne
länder und bündnisse je nach fall mit
sehr unterschiedlichen maßstäben zu
messen scheinen gut ist dass du dir aber
wahrscheinlich die frage seit wann
schätze ich russland um abstrakte
juristische feinheiten des völkerrechts
putin ist doch ein mann der tatsachen
schafft ein meister werden normativen
kraft des faktischen und liegt ist nicht
in seinem interesse den kaukasus zu
kontrollieren aber natürlich allerdings
klingen moskau und baku sid gesagt seit
einigen jahren gute beziehungen beider
länder sind aufeinander angewiesen um
ihr gas nach europa schicken zu können
zudem hat russland andere ernsthafte
probleme im kaukasus regionen wie
tschetschenien und dagestan sind immer
noch tickende bombe mit viel schlafenden
islamischen terroristen und das
allerletzte was moskau jetzt gebrauchen
kann ist dass es diese schlafend hunde
auf seinem eigenen territorium weckt in
dem es in einem krieg mit ihren
us-amerikanischen glaubensbrüdern
verwickelt wird putin liegt am 30
oktober sogar noch mal nach und betonte
können sich die rückgabe armenisch
besetzter gebiete aserbaidschan
vorstellen zuvor müssten jedoch die
kampagne haben beobachter glauben dass
russland erst dann eingreifen wird nach
nehmen wirklich bedeutende verluste
erleidet so und was ist mit der eu wäre
sie bereit in armenien unter die arme zu
greifen
das ist äußerst unwahrscheinlich denn
die eu braucht das hawaiianische gas und
ihre abhängigkeit von russland zu
verringern
mit anderen worten der türkei ist die
einzige größere macht die sich aus
diesem konflikt nicht heraushalten will
sondern umgekehrt ein enormes interesse
hat ihnen weiter anzuheizen
denn zum einen wird erdogan damit seine
nationalistische agenda und zum anderen
kann er auch diesen kriegsschauplatz die
in syrien und libyen zum austragen sein
stellvertreter krieges gegen russland
nutzen denn langfristig sehen seine
großmacht lehne eine zurückdrängung des
russischen einflusses überall davor wo
dieser seine neros manischen großmacht
fantasien im weg steht in erster linie
also aus dem kaukasus tick chancen mehr
und den kaspischen meer und all das
erklärt eben das starke interesse
moskaus so schnell wie möglich einen
waffenstillstand auszuhandeln
armenien und aserbaidschan vereinbaren
einen waffenstillstand dieser
waffenstillstand ist jedoch ohne die
türkei vereinbart worden und findet dass
dies nur ein zeitlich begrenzter stand
er nur dazu dienen dass armeen an seine
truppen aus berg karabach abziehen kann
und nur wenige stunden nach der
verabschiedung dieser sache stillstands
haben die japanischen geschütze erneut
raketen auf dem parkett abgefeuert
mittlerweile wurden zwei weitere
waffenstillstände durch russland und die
usa vermittelt diese werden aber durch
beide konfliktparteien ignoriert und
dabei gibt es erdrückende beweise und
videos schwerer kriegsverbrechen gegen
die zivilbevölkerung
eriwan beschuldigt barcoo gar verboten
sich hier die waffen einzusetzen
die arminia stehen mehr oder weniger mit
dem rücken zur wand die zeigt der immer
weiter steigenden alters meter gefallen
und soldaten lag dieser zu beginn der
kampfhandlungen noch bei 22 jahren ist
er nun auf 35 jahre angestiegen
dies zeigt dass den armeen und die
jungen soldaten aus gehen immer mehr
ältere reservisten eingesetzt werden
müssen und all dies wird
höchstwahrscheinlich weiter gehen
sondern das gleichgewicht der kräfte
welches mit der parteinahme der türkei
extrem verschoben wurde nicht wieder
hergestellt wird und all dies wird
höchstwahrscheinlich weitergehen solange
armenien nicht kapituliert oder das
gleichgewicht der kräfte welches mit
einer parteinahme der türkei extrem
verschuldet wurde nicht wieder
hergestellt wird die frage an dich
lautet nun also glaubst du dass russland
oder den nato diesen konflikt eintreten
werden um das gleichgewicht wieder
herzustellen
und noch wichtiger was denkst du über
die rolle der türkei in diesem konflikt
wird erdogan sein ziel erreichen
russland auf dem kaukasus
zurückzudrängen um sich dort mit seinem
neo osmanischen reich ungehindert
ausbreiten zu können und christen ihr
vorstellen dass sich putin die ist
einfach so gefallen lässt wie immer sind
wir auf eure aufschlussreichen
kommentare hochgradig gespannt wir
hoffen dass wir dieses video gefallen
und vielleicht auch etwas gebracht hat
was ja gebt uns auch einen daumen hoch
und unterstützen uns in hindu ist mit
deinen freunden heißt und vergesst bitte
nicht dass wir jede woche neue videos
hochladen also verpasst kann es unsere
updates abonniert unseren tollen blick
auch auf das klingeln um rechtzeitig
benachrichtigt zu werden was gut und bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]